So here are the answers. A package delivery service sounds
like a pull queue because each package is probably delivered by
independent workers that can pull tasks from the queue. What
about checking in for a flight? Well I would like to
know that I'm checked in, and in that case it's
neither a push queue nor a pull queue. Then the confirmation
would be delivered as part of the http response, even if
it takes a little bit of time. This is a situation
very similar to when you buy things using a credit
card on the internet, where you also often wait for
the response. What about code review? Well a code review
sounds like a pull queue, because you probably have many people
that can review the code, so the first one that's
available can pull the code review from the queue. And then
batch processing of images, which sounds like a push queue.
This is because your code is probably doing the processing of
the images. Therefore you want to have control over the execution.